[Musique]
certains enfants sont particulièrement
doués ils sont exceptionnels à l'école
en sport ou en musique leur cerveau
semble fonctionner différemment de la
moyenne des chercheurs découvrent peu à
peu que les enfants doués ont en commun
des forces mais aussi des fragilités et
parfois des souffrances même pour un
spécialiste du cerveau l'allégeance
c'est quoi que ça demeure un mystère
c'est une chance est très difficile à
définir de façon avec des mots en fête
mais on peut tenter de la mesurer bien
des chercheurs estiment qu'avec un qi de
130 et plus on peut parler d'un enfant
nous ayons une pensée qui est comme un
feu d'artifice le très très rapide sans
vos progrès car il peut y avoir un
revers à la médaille
faire un effort c'est pas toujours
évident pour ces élèves là
et c'est d'autant moins évident quand on
s'intéresse à tous les mathématiques
science techno ou l'éducation physique
le ska a dramatic pouces et j'aime qu'on
apprend beaucoup de choses
c'est seulement récemment une profession
aussi d'un cerveau incursion dans
l'univers de ses enfants
certes dans le cerveau fonctionne à
toute vitesse d'accord mondial vous
voulez mais le pratiquer
[Musique]
à première vue le groupe de liliane
karibe ressemble à bien d'autres classes
de 3e année
faut vous expliquant il est simple à
l'intérieur de la beauté des élèves
curieux des élèves qui questionnent
beaucoup d élèves qui veulent être en
action avec moi c'est qu'à l'école
fernand seguin à montréal on recrute
uniquement des élèves à haut potentiel
intellectuel
ils sont très forts en mathématiques
pour l'un très fort au niveau en
français pour l'eau donc ça des pins
puis en est qu'ils sont très bons dans
tous il y en a qui ils l'ont là
[Musique]
on donne aussi à ses enfants l'étiquette
de 12 ans ou encore de précocité
intellectuelle et dans le cas de simone
ses parents en ont eu la preuve
peu avant ces quatre ans un matin on
était
ac à table en train de déjeuner puis l
onu sur la bouteille de jus qui était
tropicana
je lui ai demandé c'est maintenant chose
que savait lire puis effectivement tu es
capable de lire pour moi tout ce que
voyait donc sauvé avons beaucoup donné
parce que la personne qui lui a appris à
lire en fête et depuis simone n'a jamais
arrêté de lire
elle a dévoré le premier harry potter 24
heures puis d autres qu'elle a lu et
relu jusqu'à l'usure vu que savaient
lire très tôt en anticiper que sa propre
tête est un problème de bain de passer
beaucoup de temps à l'école à apprendre
à lire en fête
d'où l'idée de se tourner vers une école
spécialisée
on s'est dit bon à vous êtes dans cet
endroit là où autrefois un
extraterrestre on veut plein d'autres
puis je me suis en première année
approche moderne à la moitié de la
classe que sexy déjà venir
on sait que cette électrode là par
exemple c'est le numéro ce week-end
c'est cette précocité qui est et reste
sara lee p elle dirige à l'hôpital
sainte justine le laboratoire des
neurosciences du développement
simone et des dizaines de ses camarades
ont pris part à ces travaux cet automne
les yeux
l'objectif c'est d'étudier le cerveau en
pleine action pendant qu'il apprend
quelque chose
audrey roux charlebois équipe simone
d'un bonnet qui va capter les moindres
courant électrique de son cerveau la
pièce est isolée de tous bruits
extérieurs et même de toute interférence
c'est parfois ce qu'on lui demande c'est
juste écouter les mots laisser son
cerveau travaille et poses but et son
cerveau doit travailler parce que les
mots qu'on lui soumet sont inventés de
toutes pièces
tony tony des pseudos mots qu'elle n'a
donc jamais entendu même dans un harry
potter en utilisant les pseudos mots on
est sûr qu'ils les connaissent pas
puisque rien d'autre qui est associée à
aucune autre activité qui est associé à
ce que juste je l'écouté je l'apprends
thorel taux réel avec le cerveau en
temps un nouveau monde il s'active et
cherche à l'apprendre mais plus on
répète le mot - cerveau réagit le signal
s'atténue il se stabilise
il ya un moment où le signal devient
stable c'est que le cerveau serait prêt
à accueillir autre chose
donc c'est un peu le signal que le viol
apprentissage qui a été fait est que là
on est dégagé pour aller vers d'autres
d'autres stimuler dans l'environnement
et cette atténuation est plus marquée
chez les enfants à haut potentiel on a
l'impression que c'est des gens qui sont
capables de capter ce qui se passe dans
leur environnement sans faire d'effort
sans effort et très rapidement chez la
moyenne des enfants le cerveau s'active
environ un tiers de seconde après le
premier pseudo mot chez les enfants
doués la réaction est non seulement plus
rapide mais différente
elle ressemble à celle de l'enfant plus
âgés bien voit ici que c'est très
précoce pour les enfants qui ont un bon
potentiel il attend cérébrale est
vraiment très précoce après le stimulus
alors que c'est un peu plus tardif
lâcher chez lui contre ogs dès l'arrivée
du stimulus dans les sphères sensorielle
la circuiterie du cerveau est très bien
organisée et très bien ficelé pour
acheminer l'information pertinente aux
beaux-arts cérébrale c'est comme s'il y
avait moins d'obstacles quand ils
traitent l'information tout sera en bon
port plus rapidement si le courant
circule plus vite et plus facilement
c'est que leur cerveau est un lieu
différent le docteur chérif karama a
relevé plusieurs caractéristiques qu'on
peut relier à un qi élevé c'est le
cortex la partie plus foncée si qu'on
voit ici aussi c'est là où on a les
noyaux des neurones et la partie
blanchissent la matière blanche c'est là
où on a le filage bien soi remarque
c'est que les gens qui ont un temps un
casse intellectuelle plus heureux plus
élevé pardon ont tendance à avoir un
cortex qui est un peu plus épais ils ont
aussi a tendance à avoir une meilleure
qualité de myéline dont de la gaine de
filage qui permet ou non de communiquer
entre eux ils ont tendance à avoir un
cerveau qui généralement plus gros comme
sa réalité ses observations s'appuie sur
le fameux cuit le quotient intellectuel
le test ne prétend pas mesurer
l'intelligence sous toutes ses formes
mais plutôt certaine habilité du cerveau
comme la perception spatiale
le raisonnement ou la mémoire de travail
des résultats qu'on compare ensuite à
ceux d'enfants du même âge
en grandissant notre cerveau se
transforme sa structure change
or chaque enfant se développe à un
rythme différent ce qui peut se refléter
dans les scores de qi
on a vu dans certains cas des
changements de cuir fenomeno où les gens
passent et de cui moyens qu en octobre 5
% la population ce qui rentrent ici
comme ça ça va super vite
le test de qi fait aussi partie des
outils de la neuropsychologue marianne
bélanger mais sa définition de la
douance va bien au delà d'un simple
chiffre la douane c'est plus que
l'intelligence
ça implique aussi un haut niveau de
créativité au niveau d'engagement de
détermination le dans envers la tâche
dans le domaine d'intérêt dans sa
clinique marianne bélanger constate que
tout n'est pas rose pour les enfants
doués
même si on est précoce sur le plan
intellectuel le développement social ou
émotif ne se fait pas à la même vitesse
je pense que c'est ce qui est le plus
visible est impressionnant c'est qu'en
fait un enfant qui s'étend d'âge chrono
léger mais au niveau de son âge mental
ou intellectuel mais pas voir presque
dix ans parfois le donc ça fait des
enfants qui vont par exemple venir
révolutionner dans la conversation les
voitures magnétique et et et deux
minutes après ils crises de colère parce
qu'on est des nombreux ouïghours loi 204
un petit peu de colère ou pour s'avérer
très très fort au rein droit de la joie
aussi par exemple pour juste la colère
la vie des enfants doués peut donc
prendre des allures de montagnes russes
et liliane karibe l'observer aussi dans
sa classe ils ont été habitués à prendre
rapidement avoir la réponse rapidement à
savoir quoi faire du premier coup donc
quand ils font face à un défi mais ça
peuvent être découragés puis être
complètement bloquées ne plus savoir
quoi faire
certains manifestent de l'anxiété de
performance donc lorsqu'ils font face
une difficulté ou un défi ils vont se
mettre à paniquer ici on mise sur un
rythme d'apprentissage élevé pour garder
l'attention de chacun et éviter de
perdre leur intérêt envers l'école j'ai
beaucoup d'enfants louis qui me disent
que ça va c'est plus intéressant dans
leur taille tels que celui finalement en
classe
donc ils peuvent vraiment se perdre un
petit peu à l'intérieur de leur pensée
quand finalement dans l'environnement
c'est pas assez rapide ou stimulant pour
eux
c'est ce qui explique qu étrangement les
enfants doués sont eux aussi très
nombreux à décrocher et pour certains la
douance peut même être accompagnés
d'autres difficultés d'un deuxième
diagnostic
on peut même ça sonne très paradoxale
avoir une douce intellectuelle est un
trouble d'apprentissage comme une sexy
donc ça ça amène un espèce de mal à être
le sait vraiment c'est vraiment très
très émotif très ça amène des
comportements qui va être opposant qui
peuvent être très difficiles à l'école
parce que ils ont tout ce potentiel il
n'arrive pas à l'exprimer
une fois je me sens bruscains que les
hommes sinon on reste toujours ça
ces comportements opposants ou encore
l'anxiété ou l'hypersensibilité sont
communs à bien des enfants doués
stressant c'est mon vrai oui et c'est
souvent ce qui poussent leurs parents à
consulter pour trouver conseils
une fois que ils comprennent et
comprennent aussi qu'une partie des
crises priyadi par sensibilité aux ados
chong bien on réoriente la façon
d'éduquer
c'est à dire que même à l'âge de 2,7 une
éducation qui doit être plus comme celle
qu'on fait avec des adolescents donc
beaucoup plus démocratique on discute on
on les laisse argumenté ils sont
intelligents ils ont besoin d'argumenter
de discuter naître avec un cerveau
toujours en ébullition est avant tout
une force c'est un don qu'il faudra
ensuite cultivé pour faire éclore un
talent c'est beaucoup d'étonnement en
fait non pas comme ça en fait elle comme
jamais c'est ce nous étonner
e